ابدا معك من التطور اللافت هذا اليوم
بعوده المعارك والاشتباكات الى قلب مدينه
غزه عبد القادر اليوم هناك تاقلم تكتيكي
يعني عندما ينسحب جيش الاحتلال الى مناطق
بعيده ويعتمد على المبدا التالي ان تجد ق
قوات حماس او ما يسمى بالنسبه ليهم العدو
ان تذهب اليه من ضمن وحده متخ خصصه حسب
المهمه ان تضرب وتعود هذا الامر يعتبر
وكانه الاقل كلفه لديه ان كان في العديد
او في العداد هذا السؤال الاول هذا تاقلم
تكتيكي وقرار عملان استراتيجي اتخذه الجيش
الاسرائيلي جيش الاحتلال في المقابل لابد
للمقاومه ان تتاقلم ايضا وتنتقل الى مرحله
حرب العصابات يعني اليوم في بدايات الحرب
على غزه كانت المقاومه تقاتل الحرب
الهجينه يعني بين التقليدي وبين حرب
العصابات اليوم حرب العصابات بالكامل
وخاصه هي ليست حرب غابات هي حرب عصابات او
حرب مدن داخل المدن في منطقه تعرفها من
هنا هذا التركيز على اماكن معينه هذا
الامر يدل ان هذه نقاط قوه للمقاومه عندما
يهاجمها الجيش الاسرائيلي وعاد الى
استعمال الطيران بشكل كثيف
طيب هذا التكنيك او هذه التقنيه ام على
حسب ما ذكرتها
الان جاءت بمعطيات ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
سحب عددا من اليته وجنوده من الشمال تجدد
الاشتباكات في هذه المناطق هل يربك حسابات
الجيش
الاسرائيلي الهدف دائما لدى المقاومه عبد
القادر هو النجاحات
التكتيكيه كل نجاح تكتيكي يعني كلما
استنزف العدو عديدا وعده وكلما طال الوقت
واستمرت المقاومه يعتبر هذا وكانه نجاح
تكتيكي اذا تراكم لفترات طويله سيؤدي الى
نجاح استراتيجي هذا النجاح
الاستراتيجي اذا تمسكت المقاومه باوراقها
سيؤدي الى تغيير سياسي لدى العدو اليوم
العدو مرغم على القيام بهذا الامر لا
يستطيع ان يقاتل بالمرحله
الاولى حرب مرتفعه الحده في الشمال في الج
في الوسط وفي الجنوب هو مضطر ان يقوم كي
يضع الاولويات اليوم اولويات العدو هي في
خان يونس طيب باشارات لخان يونس ايضا
التصريحات الاخيره للمسؤولين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين كانت تقول بانه الى حد ما
العمليات اوشكت على نهايتها كما قال وزير
الدفاع قبل يومين وان العين على رفح حسب
ما شاهدنا في الفيديوهات التي نشرتها
فصائل المقاومه قبل قليل العمليات ما زالت
مستمره في خانيونس وبالتالي ماذا ايضا عن
هذا المعطى ما يقدمه الجيش وما تقدمه
فصائل
المقاومه يسعى العدو اليوم الى روتن من
روتين يعني ان يجعل الوسط مثل الشمال
مرحله ثالثه ال الجنوب مش مثل الوسط او
شمال القطاع وبالتالي التعامل معها على
على مداه على وقته وحسب ما يراه مناسبا
لكن هذا الامر لم يحصل في خانيونس اليوم
التهديد بالذهاب الى رفح قد يكون تهديد
لرفع مستوى الردع وحشر المقاومه خلال
التفاوض لاطلاق الرهائن وحتى السجناء من
من السجون الاسرائيليه وبالتالي موضوع رفح
له تعقيدات اكثر اولا يتطلب عديد اسرائيلي
اثنين يتطلب صعوبات النازحين هذا امر
انساني كبير جدا وبالتالي موضوع كوريدور
فيلادلفيا وهذا الامر يجب ان نذهب الى
الشق المصري قبل قليل كان معنا مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي وذكر بان في هذه
الساعات هناك اشتباكات عنيفه في خان يونس
ولكن اللافت ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي نفذ
عمليه قصف منزل في رفح مباشره الحدود بين
قطاع غزه وبين الجانب المصري ماذا ايضا عن
هذا الم المؤشر في ظل تعقيدات الوضع كما
ذكرتها في
رفع هو دائما الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم بما
يسمى بروبين هو يجس النبض الهدف اليوم عبد
القادر هو اكثر دمار ممكن في كل قطاع غزه
الدمار الاكيد على
الكوريدور فيلادلفيا وبالتالي السيطر عليه
بعض الموافقه المصريه وايضا منطقه العازله
والانتقال الى شيء بسيط عادي والتعامل مع
الانفاق حسب الوقت ومع الوقت ولكن يبقى
هاجس الصواريخ التي تضرب الداخل اسرائيلي
كلها امور معينه وبدانا نرى كيف يفكر
نتنياهو هو يتحدث عن حكومه عسكريه
تحكم القطاع